hello
racist sexist homophobes and other
assorted people of the internet
yes i'm talking to all of you because
that's what you are
this is dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for september 10th
2020 and i'm only doing two stories
today
actually i've told you a couple times
i'm going to try to keep it to two or
three
four sometimes today i'm going to do two
stories and then of course tomorrow
is the 19th anniversary of 9 11 and
i come from new york i was born in new
york i was a new yorker
most of my life i've had tons of family
living in new york city i lived in new
york city
during 9 11 i want to tell you a little
bit about that you know i realized
yesterday as we were
coming up with the stories for today and
last night that
i don't know that i've ever really
talked about my experience
in 9 11 in new york city during 9 11
and for the weeks and months and
actually for the years after that
usually on 9 11 i do a little twitter
thread with some thoughts about what it
was like to be there then
but i don't think i've ever done
anything on camera talk directly to you
guys about it so i thought i'd share a
little bit about that i wrote about it a
little bit
in doper in this book but i wanted to
expand on it a little bit more so we're
just going to do
two stories of the day and then uh we'll
talk
a little bit about 911 because we're not
doing a show tomorrow
friday so uh the two big stories
that came across my desk i have a desk
and things just come across the desk
were first off this university of
michigan
at dearborn story and this is sort of
the
perfect idiotic storm
of a story that i think everyone kind of
needs to know about now
and then the other story is that trump
put out a list of potential supreme
court nominees
and he's asking biden to do the same
thing so those are the two stories that
we're going to cover today and then
we'll get to
uh some of the september 11th stuff in
in just a couple minutes
uh the university of dearborn michigan
at dearborn story
is is completely bananas completely
idiotic
and really sums up almost everything
that we're all dealing with on a
day-to-day basis right now
so the university of michigan at
dearborn they decided
to host virtual cafes
for students of color now we can have a
debate whether those types of things are
are sort of
silly unto themselves sort of creating
these safe
spaces for students of color or whatever
they consider to be marginalized groups
or all of those things
by the way i'm not inherently against
any group coming together
to talk about issues that matter to them
right that seems to be fine
but the funny thing here is that in this
case
at university of michigan they sort of
took it to the end conclusion most of
the things that we do and when we talk
about
why social justice is so screwy and why
wokeness destroys everything
it never really gets to its end
conclusion but in this case
they actually took it to its end
conclusion because they decided to have
a virtual cafe for the you know students
of color and indigenous students and
things like that and we're going to pull
up the image and i'm going to read it
exactly to you but then what would be
the natural
end of all of that well now you've got a
whole bunch of people that are excluded
so they decided
to actually have a virtual cafe
for the non-students of color
and the non-indigenous students in
effect for the white students
i thought that was the thing that we
were supposed to be against remember
that martin luther king guy
old school i know his ideas are old and
archaic
and you know he wanted his children to
be uh judged by the content of their
character not the color of their skin i
know it's just
old nonsense that we're really not
supposed to care about anymore you
should only care about people's color
and their sexuality and their gender and
things like that because that defines
everything about them if you see a black
lesbian with a limp you know everything
about her
just by that doesn't matter what she
thinks um it's all so stupid but
the reason that this story is so perfect
is because we only think about it one
way
but they actually took it the other way
and said okay no
we're gonna have a virtual cafe for you
in effect bad white people well that
didn't go over too well so let's let's
pull up the first
image uh the bi-poc this is what they
call it the black
indigenous and people of color cafe
is a space for students from
marginalized racial ethnic cultural
communities
to gather and to relate to one another
and to discuss their experience as
students on campus as
and as people of color in the world it's
hosted by the center
for social justice and inclusion
i mean the funny thing is you know all
of the words become sort of orwellian
because you're
saying it's about inclusion when you're
excluding people based on their race
and their cultural identity and their
sexuality and the rest of it
and this is why for those of you that
are new to some of this game
when we talk about the oppression
olympics right and we talk about how
this whole social justice movement it
really is just a house of cards because
it all kind of sounds right okay we're
going to take
this oppressed group you know this
perceived oppressed group
and we're going to take this suppress
group and this one and this one and this
one
and we're going to combine them together
as if together
their their power will be stronger right
their ability to change the world will
be stronger
they will all help each other except the
thing that they put
primacy on the most important thing to
people who hold this world view
is their own oppression right so once
you as a member of one of those groups
have actually graduated out of the
oppression right so if you're a black
person who is successful
a gay person who is successful a
hispanic person
who is successful they don't need you
anymore and in fact you're then a
traitor
to the cause right this is why they
absolutely what do they hate
most uh well i mean it's trump trump
trump of course it's trump
but what do they really hate it's it's
when a black person
walks away from it it's when a gay
person walks away from it or a latino
walks away from it you're an uncle tom
you're a sellout
you're a series of really what are the
worst things that
can be said and then what's even more
interesting
is when a group as a as a general idea
as a group becomes more successful then
they
turn on that group right so jews are a
cultural minority a pretty
brutal history of a couple thousand
years of a lot of pogroms and holocausts
and things of that nature
but jews through hard work and education
have graduated out of the oppression at
least at the moment
in 2020 i mean the story usually doesn't
go that well for that long
but so jews are on the outs with these
people asian people
indian people who work really hard care
about education care about family
they're really on the outs
the other one that's on the outs gay
white men because now their whiteness
is more important than their game is so
now you know
if uh if a guy like peter thiel who's
one of the great thinkers that we have
in the world
uh co-founder of of paypal and he
started palantir and a whole bunch of
other companies he's he's seated a
million
different companies in silicon valley
that are all on your phone right now
um you know the advocate will say that
he's not
gay yes he happens to be married to a
man but he's not gay because his
politics don't line up with that so
they'll actually take your sexuality
away
that's how insane this system of ideas
is that's why these people are all so
angry at each other because it's a
constant
move of controlling people in a way that
you would never want to be controlled
right you
person watching this video right now you
would never want to be judged
on the on your skin color on your
religion
on your sexuality right that's just a
little piece of you
for all of us it's just a little piece
but they're
focused on that and it's really just a
focus so that they can undermine
everything else that's good in the west
in any event they decided to have this
virtual meeting and that what i just
read there you may think it's silly
obviously i'm not on board with these
ideas
but they're that's their right to do it
but then in essence they did something
amazing here because this is what no
other school does no other school says
okay well everyone else you can have
your meeting place too so then and we'll
throw up the image
they had the non-poc cafe
this is the non-personal of color
cafe and in the non-poc cafe the
non-people of color cafe
it is a space for students that do not
identify as persons of color to gather
and discuss their experience as students
on campus and as
non-people of color in the world hosted
by the center
for social justice and inclusion so the
center for social justice and inclusion
is saying
black people latino people gays
you go there white people you go there
inclusion social justice i mean it's so
profoundly idiotic that even
even i suspect some of the people that
are in the first group
must be going uh guys
can i make a point here i think we just
created
a whites only group didn't we not want
that
on the bus we wanted everybody to be
together rosa parks could sit anywhere
on the bus that was a good thing
remember that
um but this is just the endless
stupidity
that we are faced with in 2020 and
something that i do
think more and more and more of you guys
are waking up to and hopefully
uh what i've been doing for a couple
years now has a little something to do
with it
uh they actually did issue an apology
because then of course these
pictures of the two images that i just
showed you of course these went viral
i think they were originally from
instagram uh they went viral on twitter
and then what do we do this is 2020. so
we issue apologies and corrections and
uh the statement said we'll throw it up
um-dearborn sincerely regrets the terms
used to describe the cafe events
held on september 8th the terms used to
describe these virtual events and the
descriptions themselves were not
clear and not reflective of the
university's commitment
to diversity equity and inclusion
now of course the funny thing is that it
actually was
right like they did exactly
what all of these diversity equity and
inclusion or diversity offices whatever
they're calling them now
they did exactly what these offices have
been calling for
and if you're going to create if you're
going to say that identity immutable
identity is the most important thing
that's out there
there is going to be a counter movement
to it well then white
people and straight people and whoever
else is left
out of the thing that you say is the
most important thing they're going to
create their own groups now in this case
you just did it for them um
but this is do you see why this
thing guys this thing is a cancer that
is
that is reaching its tentacles and
spreading throughout society and
we have a limited amount of time before
it completely infects the host in many
regards i think you could say that this
election
is basically that like that's almost
what it comes down to more than anything
else because
this terrible set of ideas is just
the the table setting for almost
everything else we're
fighting about right now because as
bizarre as it sounds
even though america in its 240 plus
years has brought
more economic success and more freedom
to all of the
groups that are perceived to be
oppressed uh
it seems to be debatable well whether
any of this was good or not and that
really
in many ways i would say that and
whether you want your cities to burn
down or not are going to be the two
issues that are sitting on the table
more than anything else when it comes to
the election in two months
uh because you if you think about it
this way it's like is foreign policy
really going to be a big thing this year
it doesn't really seem like it right i
mean i talked about yesterday it seems
like
we're on the verge of some really big
peace things in the middle east doesn't
seem like that's going to be something
we would really vote about
um so some of the usual stuff
that we're usually voting about even
healthcare right now doesn't seem like
the thing that we're
all really thinking about right we think
there's a pandemic or whatever the hell
is going on with coronavirus
and then there's cities burning down and
then just watching all of our
institutions crumble that
is the thing that is the thing that i
think is going to be sitting in most
people's mind
when they go to the the ballot box so
anyway i thought this story was
interesting because it's a perfect
example
of you know when i say that the road to
hell leads to good intentions do i think
that all of the people
who create these inclusion offices and
diversity offices
and virtual cafes do i think that
they're all evil
of course i don't i don't i do think
some of the leaders at the top and some
of their political leaders are are
manipulating them and are and are
evil in that sense but i think the
students that come here they've been
indoctrinated with terrible ideas that
have been taught to them
now at public schools which is a whole
other issue
uh that we'll get into more over the
next couple of weeks because i think
we're watching also
the fruits of a bad education system a
system that once was good by the way i
i'm a product of
total public education from elementary
school middle school high school
college there there was good public
education but but social justice as it
infects
everything destroys everything whether
it's a public education system or
whether it's a corporation
or whether it's a religious institution
which we're seeing even religious
institutions crumble under it right now
but this story was particularly
interesting because they they did it
they did it not only we're gonna give
you guys a special space you want your
safe space
but now whites and straights you got one
too and
and let's fight it out so it's just
craziness and a perfect example of
the the stuff that is wrong in the world
right now uh let's move over to the
the second story which is that donald
trump president of the united states
some people say he's your president
right well he's your president they go
well i think you live here too
uh he released a list of 20 potential
supreme court
nominees and then he challenged joe
biden to do the same now
uh it looks like without question over
the course
of the four years of the next president
whether it's trump or biden
or whoever they replace biden with or
whatever else
that at least one supreme court nominee
will be replaced
ruth bader ginsburg obviously her health
is not great and she's 80
plus years old um and they seem to be
sort of
i think both sides are sort of seeding
the ground for it now i always find the
debates about
supreme court nominees to be a little
disingenuous because
you know the way the system is supposed
to work supposed to work
is we've got the three branches i know
you guys know about the three branches
what do we got we got the legislative
branch they write the laws
we've got the executive branch they sign
the laws
and then we've got the judicial branch
and what do they do the judicial branch
actually makes sure
that the laws are legal okay so those
are the three branches
that we've got so each one of those
branches does what they're supposed to
do
or is supposed to do what they're
supposed to do and then that's how we
have checks and balances that's how we
make sure
that no part of the system of government
gets too powerful or anything like that
now
one of the problems that we have right
now and i think we've probably had
for a couple decades at least and this
is just i think a condition of the human
mind is that we've put a tremendous
amount of disproportionate attention
and in that regard power on the
executive branch
in that why did we leave england
why'd we leave england we didn't want to
be ruled by a king right they had a king
and we didn't like that we wanted our
own representation right no taxation
without representation
well we've put so much emphasis on
the president that we sort of look at
the president like a king so when people
are like
you know biden's going to do this for me
or trump's going to do this for me and
it's like
actually the president isn't supposed to
do that much
um but one of the things that the
president is supposed to do is nominate
supreme court nominees then
it goes to congress and senators and the
house of representative
they vote on the nominees and it's not
supposed to be done
on a purely partisan basis so while it's
not supposed to be done on a purely
partisan basis as you guys know we've
devolved into where everything is if
you're republican you vote this way
you're democrat
you vote this way so i think trump in in
this regard he's trying to get a little
ahead of the game and he's saying look
if you vote for me
you know that i'm gonna have to nominate
somebody in these four years
here's 20 people and he's basically
saying to the media he's saying to
anyone that votes for him he's saying to
all the political insiders
vet these guys accordingly in a weird
way i guess this isn't even in a weird
way
he's doing sort of a reality tv version
of this which i actually don't think is
terrible because if
if it really is true that he would
select someone out of these 20 people
well now we have a ton of advanced time
to look into all of them right
and the funny thing is that let's let's
say trump wins reelection and he
nominates one of these people now we
know the media is going to go crazy and
they're going to say he was
he was a rapist or a murderer or just
all of the the horrible
things i mean just go back to the brett
kavanaugh hearings and you know it
doesn't matter what you've done or what
you've
what your life's work has led to uh if
you're nominated especially by a
republican they're gonna say awful
things with you but you know the reverse
of that is true
you're nominated by a democrat the
republicans are going to say awful
things okay fine
um but i think he's doing a reality
version here which is guys you vet them
and he's letting sort of he's letting
sort of the
the whole world in effect he's letting
the world go
okay we kind of like this guy we don't
like this guy you know he's letting it
sort of shake out so
you're gonna you're not gonna know a lot
of the names on the list um really i
would say probably the
unless you're a real insider or a real
like legal scholar
type um but the two or three let's say
that you will know
for sure tom cotton uh ted cruz
and there was one other uh josh howley
now these are these are really
interesting picks uh those three
obviously are republicans um look i want
to just talk about ted cruz for a second
so ted cruz i've had him on the show you
may have seen it
uh we did it probably in mid-july uh he
i think ted cruz was the last
interview that i did in the old studio
the last live interview that i did in
the whole studio and you may remember
kind of funny insider thing that uh
remember ted cruz got in trouble because
someone
on a plane took a picture of him
drinking starbucks and he didn't have
his mask on now
he said later well i couldn't drink
starbucks with a mask on on the plane so
i did
take the mask now to drink the starbucks
but somebody found that moment
and they sent out a picture and then i
think it was united had to issue a
statement and blah blah blah
well ted cruz brought that starbucks cup
into my house
and so now it was like the number one
trending thing on twitter and we're like
well we've got
the very cup um and i think we still
have it actually
um in any event ted cruz i think is well
first off i think he's a good guy
all right he's he's a good guy he's a
real person
um you know one of the things that is a
privilege in the right sense of the word
privilege for me is that i get to sit
down with a lot of these people usually
just a couple feet away from them really
kind of figure out what they think
this is a guy who has thought seriously
about these issues you know he went to
harvard law school
uh i think alan dershowitz i'm going to
roughly get this quote correct
called him his his smartest student that
he had ever had his best debater
that he had ever had um i asked cruz
this in our interview i think he may
have done things a little bit
differently
uh in the 2016 run which at the end it
was really just him versus
trump and he's become one of trump's big
supporters i think trump was probably
willing to fight the media
in a way that cruz wasn't that's just a
little bit of the personality makeup
but i have no doubt that ted cruz is an
absolutely excellent
scholar and has tremendous knowledge
of the constitution and i think he would
probably be a really great choice i also
think that
you know since he's gotten the beard and
it has something to do with the beard i
started the beard trend right nobody had
a beard before me
out on youtube uh that since he's got
the beard he's become a little
more a little more feisty he gets into
it a little bit more i think he's gotten
a little more
a little more juice anyway the purposes
of this story really are
not to make it about ted cruz or josh
halley or anybody else but i think it's
interesting here
that the executive in this case the
president would say
here's potentially what i'm doing guys
here's potentially it you vet him now
and then we'll see when we get there
that actually seems like a good level of
transparency right now i guess legally
nothing's holding him to that so
the media could wreck all of these 20
people and then he could pick someone
else but i think the general idea here
of these are
these are these are the people
who think a certain way who use
their judicial power in a certain way or
what will be their judicial power in a
certain way i know sort of how they
think
and you vet them and then ultimately
will decide i think that's a pretty good
idea
i think it would be great if biden
actually did the same thing
and what i would hope more than anything
else is that when we get to the
nomination process which probably
happens let's say in the next year or
two
that people can slightly get over the
partisan politics part of it
i would like that to happen i don't
suspect that actually will happen
um but really remember what the the
chaos was during the brett kavanaugh
thing and how insane it was i was
actually
on tour with jordan peterson at the time
and i remember we were in ireland in
dublin
doing a show and a guy came up to me on
the street and was going what do you
think about brett kavanaugh
and i remember thinking i was like this
is bananas i'm across the world
and people in dublin are asking me about
what our supreme court nomination
process is
going what's happening with it in the
states and it's like that that is just
bananas
all right i want to move on and use the
remaining time uh just a couple minutes
to talk about 9 11
um because tomorrow is the 19th
anniversary of 9 11. it's hard to
believe
that it's 19 years and for any of you
guys that were
alive and of age when you're when you
can make memories i
i have no doubt that you remember the
day uh just as i do whether you were
in new york city like i was or or
wherever you were
whether you were in the states or
anywhere else
so i just want to spend a couple of
minutes talking about my experience
in new york city during 9 11 because i
think we forget some of the human stuff
and i have no doubt
that unfortunately tomorrow we'll all be
fighting about politics the way
that we do and and getting further and
further away
from what new york city but the country
was actually like for a while for a good
while after 9 11 where we really did put
a lot of this stuff aside
and there was sort of an incredible
national feeling
i mean every time i see the video of
george bush going out
in the world series yankee stadium to
throw out that pitch and he throws a
perfect strike
say what you want about george w bush
but the guy threw a perfect strike like
that
feeling it i truly i've gotten chills
down my spine
many times while watching that um at the
time so this is 2001. i was
about 25 years old i was living in new
york city i lived on 90th
between first and york so those of you
that know new york city
this is far upper east side and it's a
really bizarre spot 90th between first
and york because to get to the subway
i had to walk i was closer to york which
is basically as east as you can get it's
about a block away from
gracie mansion which is the the mayor's
mansion actually
and uh to get to the subway there i had
to walk to first avenue to second avenue
to third avenue
to lex then to 89th 88th 87th and then
the subway was on 86th and lex so it was
a really bizarre
spot to to live in and
at the time i had i had actually just
got laid off from a job it was just some
some office job that i was doing and i
was doing stand-up at night
and i got a call in the morning actually
remember i just got a cell phone
so that tells you about how the world
changes right i just got a cell phone i
had a little nokia black little
i think it was like a candy bar i think
that's what they called it all you could
do is play snake on that thing wasn't
even color
um and i got a call that morning from my
dad and my dad worked in the city
in midtown on about 36th street and 7th
or so
and uh he told me that a plane had hit
the
one of the towers of the world trade
center and i should turn on the tv and
everything else and that he could see it
from his office
um because he had he had a view straight
downtown he had a great office
in the city um and then of course you
know a few minutes later the second
tower hit and then and then we knew
something
something horrible was happening and i
remember the feeling of like
like the world is melting away like
everything that we know in the world is
kind of melting away i was i was home
alone i had two roommates who were who
were at work so now
you know this is around nine something i
guess probably around 9 30 or so
and you know like everybody else i i was
glued to the tv i was
freaking out and trying to think of all
my friends i had a lot of friends that
worked down in the financial district
and i was trying to think of who to call
and you couldn't even
immediately you basically couldn't make
calls on cell phones
um but then then uh occasionally if call
would get through
and you know i had i had a friend who
actually was an intern at the daily show
at the time i had been an intern at the
daily show before that and i helped my
friend ed get a job
and he called he suddenly got through
and he had started walking from the west
side
because he lived in the suburbs and it
was very obvious from the beginning
people weren't going to be able to get
out of the city
so he started walking across town to
stay with me and i had a couple friends
that couldn't get out that stayed with
me that night
my dad ended up staying at my grandma
who lived on the east side with some of
the people from his office because none
of them could get out of the city
and i just more than anything i just
remember the feeling like oh the old
like it's all everything we thought we
knew like we don't know like now we're
under attack and we have to remember
they were thinking at that time that
there were all these other planes and
then the pentagon thing happened
and the plane in pennsylvania and
everything else and that that really
horrific feeling of like you just think
the world is gonna be okay
and then it's just not okay
i remember walking out to to first
avenue and i wanted to go to the store
because i suddenly thought all right
we better stock up on stuff who knows
what's going on here like we didn't know
what was going to happen like were there
suddenly going to be bombings all over
the city or or what
and i remember i went to this just like
little local
bodega there and as i was walking in
within this must have been within 45
minutes or so
maybe an hour um you could smell it and
i was far i mean i was on 90th street
so that's uptown and you know obviously
world trade center that's downtown
um but you could smell the soot and the
concrete and
and i didn't even want to think what
else you're smelling in the air at the
time
and i remember i bought i bought some
bread i brought some gatorade
um and just a bunch of stuff and then i
remember
seeing as i walked out and i started
looking downtown so i'm on first
avenue looking downtown and just seeing
thousands of people
walking up in the middle of the street
right because they were at that point
cars had sort of
started disappearing and people are just
kind of shell-shocked
just walking uptown just to people
trying to get home
and you know over the next couple days
and everything else
we were just glued to the tv if you want
to watch an interesting interview that i
did a year ago i think i did it a year
ago today
on september 10th i had aaron brown on
and aaron brown was the cnn anchor who
who handled most of their 911 stuff
and he did an actually remarkable job
like an actual old-school
non-alarmist journalist just did a
wonderful job
um but in the following weeks i remember
about 10 days after 9 11 and it was just
weird it was just there's no way to
describe it properly actually
but i remember about 10 days after i
thought alright i got to get out of the
house like i just got to get out of the
house and i grabbed my basketball
and i went over to gracie mansion and
there were some basketball courts right
outside over there and i didn't know if
anyone else was going to be there but i
was like i got to get out
you could still smell the soot and the
stuff in the air
so like especially if you're gonna be
running around it was like kind of gross
but i got in a pickup game a little four
on four pickup game full court with
with a bunch of guys i don't think
anyone knew anybody on the court but we
were all just kind of out there and
there was just like this weird feeling
like we're kind of looking at each other
like all right
are we even allowed to play basketball
right now anyway we started playing and
then at one point one guy elbowed
another guy
and they got in each other's face it
happens and they started screaming at
each other
and i kid you not at almost the exact
same time they both started crying
like adult men just crying they kind of
hugged each other and we all kind of
teared up
and then you know we finished we
finished playing and
and that was it but i remember that that
moment for some reason strikes me as
like the most
it's like the most new york city moment
that that there is like we survived this
horrific thing together
we we came together yet there's that new
york city part where you're going to
fight with somebody in a second and then
there was something bigger than all of
us that brought us all together
there's a million stories like this i it
turned out that i knew
i didn't know anyone myself directly
miraculously that died in 9 11 but i had
a lot of people that i know that either
a parent or an uncle or a cousin or
something else
because basically anyone that lived in
the tri-state area if you lived in new
york jersey or connecticut you were
somehow
connected to somebody uh that died i had
a couple friends who's
had to move apartments and a whole bunch
of other stuff but that moment just that
that sort of simple human moment is what
sticks with me more than anything else
and uh and i hope i hope that in
these crazy times that we seem to live
in right now that maybe tomorrow
we'll be able to get back to a little
bit of what that feeling was like after
you know like i could sit here all day
long and tell you about the workstars
and and the crazy leftists and the
progressives and all that and i have all
my frustrations
but like if this project is to continue
this american project we're gonna have
to figure out a way
to to build some roads forward um
and there was a feeling after 9 11 that
that maybe we could there was
some national unity we don't have a lot
of it right now i don't know exactly how
we get back to it and i certainly hope
it doesn't take another you know tragedy
of that magnitude to get us there
um but that's that's uh that's my memory
that's my main memory of uh
it changed everything obviously i'd love
to to read some of your stories if you
guys want to throw some comments in the
comments section right down below
and that is the direct message for
september 10th
2020 and i will see you guys next week